what's going on reject nation I just got
back from working out and that's some
when I sweat my hair gets even curlier I
got this like curly french fry thing
going on right now that was on YouTube
and I saw that an epitope your
enthusiasm season nine drop and I
realized I hadn't seen the last episode
of season eight it's something I do
which shows that I don't want to say
goodbye to okay I have this habit if if
it's like available on streaming if I
get to like the last couple episodes
like I remember read it's a good boy
yeah and then I just I'm not watching
this episode now that they're back I
would realize you know I could I'm gonna
watch the last episode so I just watch
the last episode I forgot how frickin
hilarious this funny yeah that's my
little spiel on why I'm doing this
reaction that damn dog
and today's shout-out goes out to a new
patron today and his name is Jay and
valent evil int a I'll give you a shout
out after the reaction my friend
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
see back in LA
[Music]
I enjoy the mind yes
oh my god it's oh yay I love this show
seriously today's the day I saw it see
that I've imported it for so long in the
last episode of season 8 and then Xia
Beck you know what I love about this
Curb Your Enthusiasm is especially with
Curb Your Enthusiasm you know how dumb
and dumber to would like is just kind of
annoying from the beginning because it's
like uh-huh they haven't changed one bit
in all these years it's been decades and
they're still the same and that's just
kind of annoying and it's like it's
trying to be the first time in dumber
and what Curb Your Enthusiasm you know
there's there tends to be long breaks in
between the seasons you never go when
the [ __ ] was actually done it's one of
the fun things about it like it might
come back we don't know it all depends
on what Larry David wants to do the
trailer of you know really establishing
that nothing's changed she's the exact
same guy who's gonna piss off everyone
he knows with cuz he just is way too
honest about his own personal opinion
and I actually like the beginning of
this trailer that like self-awareness
why hasn't he come back where's Larry
David Ben where's Curb Your Enthusiasm
is it gonna come back and it sounds like
he's kind of saying that to the audience
I know in that scene he's saying all
that stuff to a judge but saying like I
did this for you not for me you know
kind of like how bo burnham tends to do
some of his specials today I'm happy
they're back I'm excited to tell you
[ __ ] school scene Bryan Cranston in here
and I'm happy because a lot of the times
you know like the last episode they tend
to have celebrities guests around here
and sometimes celebrities are characters
and I feel like Bryan Cranston's in the
position where he could definitely play
himself and it'd be fascinating but I'm
more excited that he's playing I think
it was his therapist so if he has a
therapist for so fascinating Missy Larry
David Gordon
there yeah I'm excited for this season
dude I'm gonna I have hbi this is the
first year I've owned HBO Go and I've
been watching HBO stuff lately so yay
before I would I bought all of like I
bought all the seasons of Curb Your
Enthusiasm on Amazon thanks for tuning
in
but before this video is done got to
give a shout out to Jay and Valente for
your shout out I'm gonna read for the
people at YouTube your very first
response to me I said hey dude thanks so
much for joining our patreon where are
you from my friend Jay and how I imagine
he sounds like this my pleasure
very much so entirely I'm from Croydon
South London England raised in Toronto
went to college in Scotland worked with
a family business and Portugal into the
folded and now back in Croydon for most
of the year been onto the last day of
summer I always go slash come back to
Portugal for summer despite the
wildfires in the suburbs and the
excessive heat waves by the beach or in
the woods
this year's major won't even merited a
name Lucifer just like every major
natural disaster except he waves of this
magnitude seen most unnatural rambling
on wasn't I sorry about that I tend to
keep that not for first impressions
short answer I am from South London and
mostly live there I do have a job but
it's online so I am a citizen at the
part of the world that has high speed
Wi-Fi or broadband was my first
instinctive answer you rock
you rule your crazy funny but crazy
eclectic as well man then stay cool or
hot or slaying or shouting like crazy
diamonds whatever tickles your fancy the
most I guess all kinds of best wishes in
your your professional and personal
lives projects undertakings friends and
families may they all prosper I gave a
reply not as interesting as that I want
to say I love that answer Jan most of
the time you asked where you from you
get like a sentence no no you did the
exact opposite of what people do on
first impressions you gave me a life
story I said where are you from
you told me the origin of JN valent a
Valente
and well I'm happy you're part of the
patreon oh sorry reg our private fish
you could subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell follow dad
John Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram
I'm just used to saying that he's out
taking care of some stuff right now
now there's livin here you know he goes
takes care of all the eel I could be the
life stuff go take out the trash and
stay out there till I'm done filming
yeah I guess I'm shooting from the
webcam now it just feels more
comfortable in natural